I have probably the toughest skin on the
planet because millions of people have
said things about me decided who I am
that's not even me it's hard to like
just swallow that Kylie Jenner may be
one of the reigning Queens of social
media thank you but she explains why
nowadays she's not posting all that much
there's just people that are always
going to come and say mean comments the
more people who love you the more people
that are going to be there's going to be
who hate you the Kylie Cosmetics founder
joins her friend Haley Bieber dressed as
a witch for a special Halloween episode
of Haley's YouTube series who's in my
bathroom and in it Kylie opens up about
her relationship with social media I
think that when I showed my personality
too much or shared a little bit too much
people just had more access to say
things about the real me so I decided to
push back a little bit Kylie has over
372 million followers on Instagram alone
but the mom of two says that when she
got pregnant and started to have kids
she started to care less about her
online presence
I think that I just have a different
relationship with social media and I
think my priorities are just in a
different place and I really have real
life to do now I think before when I was
on social media I dedicated my whole
life to that I would wake up I would
Snapchat my breakfast you know I just
can't do that anymore but that doesn't
mean Kylie is done giving fans an inside
look at her personal life deep down like
I would love my true fans to know like
all my personal stuff in fact on
Halloween Kylie posted a sweet mere
selfie with her boyfriend Travis Scott
and their two kiddos four-year-old
daughter stormy and their
eight-month-old son whose name has not
yet been revealed we are doing a little
Halloween get-together before
trick-or-treating how cute are these the
Kardashian crew gathered at Kylie's
house for the spooky holiday and she
documented some of the sweet family
moments like stormy posing it up solo
dressed as an angel and and with
stormy's cousin Chloe's four-year-old
daughter true over here
of course all this comes just days after
Travis shut down rumors he cheated on
Kylie with Instagram model rojin Carr
you cheat on that every single [ __ ]
night the whole [ __ ] City sees it
don't do this the rapper posted this
message to Instagram quote I'm saying
this for the last time I don't know this
person I've never been with this person
so please stop with A continuous cyber
games and the fictional storytelling to
say you don't know me and you've never
been with me when you've definitely been
with me when everybody's seen you with
me when I have pictures and videos of
you with me come on
come on Sir back in August A source told
ET that things between the couple were
going super well adding that they have
really mastered being together as for
Kylie she says she just takes all the
online chatter in stride I think that
things get over analyzed and
misconstrued and you kind of just have
to accept that I think that I have
probably the toughest skin on the planet
because millions of people have said
things about me decided who I am that's
not even me it's hard to like just
swallow that my friends and my family
know who I am so that's really all that
matters
[Music]
thank you